we're getting our first look inside the  mlk junior senior center after it's  remodeled the project added 7 500 square  feet and focused on areas that are  challenging for seniors like hunger and  isolation organizers also launched many  programs to keep at risk seniors safe  and improve their quality of life they  say the center has become a reliable  location for resources  we have a great project called a legacy  rock project  we also have some programs that center  around art  around health  we have a  big push on mental illness  the renovation also includes state of  the art software so staff can  communicate with seniors who are still  homebound because of the pandemic